des patients sont si derrière moi cette
affaire fait la une de l'actualité en
franche comté depuis plusieurs années le
professeur philippe humbert accuse le
chu majeau de ne pas respecter le
protocole cancer selon lui auraient été
prescrites trop de chimiothérapie qui
serait a priori davantage rémunératrice
pour l'hôpital au détriment d'actes de
chirurgie la rs l' agence régionale de
santé a diligenté une inspection qui a
examiné 63 dossiers de patients dont 18
atteints de cancer elle a conclu que ces
accusations étaient je cite infondées ce
n'est qu'en septembre 2010 est que lors
d'une conférence de presse
la direction du chu mage au sort enfin
de son silence
elle dénonce le discrédit jeté sur les
professionnels de santé
elle porte plainte pour diffamation
contre le professeur humbert le
professeur philippe humbert se dit
harcelé par l'hôpital
l'ancien chef de service en dermatologie
se considère lui comme un lanceur
d'alerté